you say to somebody you gotta see this
movie that I just so you really eagerly
recommend the movie thing just so it's
because you've got caught up in the
story not the editing I see the Academy
Award for editing huh you don't know if
the editing has been done really well
you don't even notice the editing
supposed to be sort of invisible the
know there's this expression on Broadway
they don't come out whistling the
scenery
you can't people don't go I love
beautiful cinematography but if that's
what you have it's really really old in
about five minutes there's gotta be a
story it's all about story I'll tell you
in the earliest days of movies 100 years
ago now about a hundred ten years ago
well actually going back almost under
thirty hundred forty years to the
invention of the motion picture camera
Thomas Edison and all of that the very
first image ever the very first moving
picture image ever recorded is a trolley
a trolley car moving down the Main
Street of Orange New Jersey
why in the world how did that in the
world did that come to be the first a
moving picture image and the answer is
first of all that's where Edison's
studio was and when he was finished
building the camera he needed a lot of
light so he went outdoors and wanted a
photograph something moving you know
invent a moving picture camera and then
try it out on a Vaz with a rose in it
you know you want something that moves
well they have trolley cars going down
the Main Street there and at that time
in that town in New Jersey and so he
photographed that and for a number of
years people would just blown away you
know they were stunned to see a picture
that moved but very quickly that became
wearying all right been there done that
adios so then they started to have
scenes moving pictures for more on the
world from the great you know
the wonders of the world some of the
very earliest moving picture images are
of benin tribesmen in flowing robes
riding camels past the pyramids at giza
in egypt the Great Wall of China with
Chinese indigenous Chinese making their
way with carts along the wall on the
wall next to the wall the they shot very
very early images of the Victoria Falls
or in South America Iguazu Falls with
Amazonian natives in their native garb
this great cascading waterfall so people
were were excited to see that stuff for
a little while you know because it
wasn't just moving but it was famous
stuff you no longer had to bother to go
to Egypt to see the pyramids you could
watch it and in a movie theater I think
probably it's a better experience to see
it in person but the point is after a
while everybody was bored with that
after a very little while and then comes
1902 or three or four or five I don't
remember exactly when and it's the the
Great Train Robbery suddenly it's a
story a narrative it's been creative
that that they made up likewise the mil
gayi brothers in France doing triptychs
journey to the moon trip to the moon
whatever it was called an actual story
that they made up and that they filmed
everything has changed since then movies
are no longer shorts they're long
they're no longer in black and white
they're in color they're no longer
silent they have sound nowadays with
with mobile you know with mobis ODEs TV
series is all different kinds of lengths
of films so there's been a tremendous
amount of change but one thing has not
changed has not changed in a hundred and
ten years and that is story it's all
about narrative it's all about story now
and that's what will get people to to go
to the movies not some technical
achievement
but a creative artistic achievement that
is again the creation of a dramatic
narrative the telling of a story it's
all about story
you